welcome everyone thank you for joining
us at navigating spatial biology take
that next step with Leica biosystems our
first presentation for today is
cytometric analysis of immune cell
populations in archives clinical ffpe
biopsies for immuno-oncology research
presented by Tom villani my name is
Marie and I will be your moderator for
today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation
to ask a question click on the Q a box
located on the bottom of your screen
type your questions and hit submit
the speaker will answer your questions
following the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the Q a
box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
please join me in welcoming Tom for a
complete biography on our speaker visit
the biography tab on the left Tom over
to you
hi everybody and thanks so much Maria
for the invite to give this presentation
today my name is Tom belani I'm going to
be giving an overview of the cytometric
analysis of immune cell populations in
archived clinical ffpe biopsies for
amino oncology research
so before we dive in I wanted to give a
little introduction about the company
that I work for physical we're an
industry leader in advanced models and
tissue Imaging we're focused on
improving and it's accelerating drug
Discovery and development through our
contract Research Services
um we're an Innovative and profitable
company based in the US and offered
Research Services for drug Discovery and
development as well as clinical research
we have a worldwide customer base of
startups small medium and large Pharma
and a number of prestigious research
institutions
our team is composed of a number of
experts in drug Discovery assay design
oncology Immunology inflammation liver
disease on many other therapeutic areas
we leverage that expertise to do several
hundred drug screening pre-clinical and
clinical campaigns per year
we have dozens of unique Technologies
and patents related to histology tissue
Imaging 3D cell culture and other kinds
of Advanced Techniques for biological
research and our two main pillars of our
business are our Advanced tissue Imaging
services and our Advanced cell culture
and tissue model assay services
so um a brief overview of the
presentation today
um so this presentation is going to be
focused on how we extract cytometric
data from ffpe tissues
um and towards that end I wanted to
start with a brief overview of immuno
oncology which is an emerging and one of
the leading paradigms in cancer research
these days
um we'll touch base with a brief
overview of flow cytometry and its
applications to cancer research we'll
talk about some of the limitations of
flow cytometry when applied to clinical
specimens especially archived specimens
um we'll dive into some applications of
our ffpe technique for doing cytometry
on tissue sections and conclude with an
overview of some of the limitations in
the future directions we're going with
these techniques
so to start off immuno oncology has been
a a rapidly emerging Paradigm in cancer
research over the last decade or so and
this is of course essentially unlocking
the power of the immune system to help
fight cancer
um over the past 10 years there's been
an explosion of interest in
understanding the the interaction
between the immune system and how it
responds when a tumor is is growing and
there's been a huge amount of
development towards pharmaceutical
strategies to leverage the immune system
to kind of help out
um in fighting cancer
a lot of us started in the 70s and early
80s as we were learning more about the
immune system to try to combat AIDS it
was understood that T cells were able to
attack cancer cells
um in some clinical experiments by the
late 80s it was shown that we could
genetically engineer T cells to
recognize and attack tumor cells
directly into the 90s there was a lot of
research done looking at adoptive cell
therapy and understanding immune
checkpoint inhibition and by the early
2000s there was already the first
clinical trials to test immune
checkpoint inhibiting drugs the first
one was tested in 2000 it was approved
in 2011 it's epilimumab also known as
urvoy and by 2012 the first child with
leukemia had been treated with car T
Cell Therapy
over the last five ten years there's
been a huge amount of developments
keytruda was approved in 2016. the FDA
granted accelerate approval to
avalimumab a pdl1 checkpoint inhibitor
for Merkel cell carcinoma and with all
the success in a very short period of
time there's been an explosion of
interest in research in this space and
there's a huge a number of companies
right now seeking to modulate the immune
response to try to treat cancer
so let's step back for a second and talk
a little bit about flow cytometry flow
cytometry is a critical tool for
understanding immunology and really for
diving into the the population of cells
um flow cytometry is used to quantify
cells but they need to be suspended um
so that you can run them through the
flow cytometer
um so in a flow cytometer we measure the
intensity of the fluorescent signal of
the individual cells we typically
um you know get them to be fluorescent
by Amino labeling
um we also can measure the diameter and
the refraction slash reflection and this
allows us to analyze the populations of
cells by selected parameters such as the
intensity ranges size and shape and this
gating allows us to do multi-parametric
analysis on complex cell populations to
really quickly count cells understand
changes in phenotypes protein expression
to understand the composition of the
immune cells that are located in a
tissue understand differences in the
cell cycle understand cell death
apoptosis activation of immune cells and
there's obviously a wide variety of
applications that flow cytometry is
critical for and it's routinely used in
in research obviously and also in
clinical practice such as for human
um so Volcan damage has been a critical
tool for a long time it allows us to
take extremely complex populations of
cells and essentially come up with a
systematic way to evaluate differences
in those populations and how they might
change or shift due to treatments or or
the progression of a disease
in immuno oncology it's incredibly
important to understand the immune cell
population within the tumor and so this
is typically done in research via
homogenization of a culture tumor or a
fresh biopsy sample
um they essentially disincorporate the
cells decellularize the tissue and then
label it put it into the flow cytometer
and then can do this multi-parametric
analysis to understand the different
cell the different immune cell
populations in the specimens that
they're looking at
um determining the relative receptor
expression is in the immune cell
subpopulations is critical to understand
the mechanisms of oncogenesis resistance
and drug effect and so at the end of the
day the more data that you can get about
these cell populations the more
information that you can then uncover
about the the different factors that
contribute to the progression of the
tumor itself
so um a brief overview of flow cytometry
and cancer research so obviously there's
a lot of Pros it's very high throughput
and highly automatable you can do high
Flex labeling so it's easy to do 7 10 15
labels on a single population of cells
it's extremely quantitative and you get
very high statistical power due to the
the sheer number of cells that you're
measuring
um it's got widespread adoption and
familiarity most immunologists are
familiar with how to read these Scatter
Plots
um and of course A major advantage that
you can recover viable sordid cells for
further experimentation
now there are some limitations to flow
cytometry
um flow cytometry can only measure the
total of signal it can't really
distinguish between the specificity of
staining of internal structures
um and sometimes this is important for
um for different phenotypes another
major con is that you lose all of the
spatial information in the tissue since
you have to disincorporate the tissue
you end up with just a mixture of cells
and you don't know which ones were near
which others and that can be a
difficulty when you're trying to
quantify the changes in the immune cell
population in terms of how close the
immune cells are to interacting with one
another or to the tumor cells
furthermore only suspended cells can be
put through a flow cytometer and as I
mentioned you have to disaggregate these
tissues using enzymes and so because of
this you can't use flow cytometry on
archived formal and fixed paraffin
embedded tissue specimens it's just not
an option now of course
a huge amount of the tissue specimens
stored in the world from former clinical
trials and research are stored as ffpe
tissue blocks and so enabling a
technique that would allow us to do this
type of immune cell population analysis
on ffpe tissues will be very valuable to
cancer research and to research in
general
So to that end we sought to develop a
technique to do exactly that we wanted
to characterize the immune cell
populations in these archival tissues to
take advantage of the millions of
archived tissue specimens that Pharma
clients
research depositories universities
research hospitals Etc have at their
disposal the most critical aspect is
that these these these stored clinical
archive samples have a huge amount of
information about you know the
progression of the patient's disease and
Etc so this represents an extremely
large repository of information about
disease that we can get access to so how
are we going to do this so the way that
we accomplished this was to adapt the
multiplex immunofluorescent techniques
that we had developed for doing High
Plex immunohistochemistry using digital
slide scanning and we developed some
open source Data Mining and
visualization tools that allowed us to
develop what we call tissue cytometry
this is essentially doing the same exact
kind of analysis where you're measuring
the intensity and count of the different
cells in your in your sample but we're
doing it in situ so directly from the
ffpe slide
so how does this work the approach is
essentially sequential multi-round
immuno labeling so the way that this
works is by taking a tissue section
labeling with three to five antibodies
then we do digital fluorescent slide
scanning after that we strip the
antibodies off the tissue using a
proprietary reagent that we developed
here we repeat this process over and
over until we've covered all the targets
on that same tissue then we use a
computational co-registration algorithm
to assemble this into one big Mega stack
of an image that contains all the
different channels and that allows us to
conduct quantitative analysis where we
do cell counting co-localization
intensity gating Etc
so um this is a brief overview of how
our approach works and some of the
preliminary information to to
demonstrate why we can use it this way
um so the approach that we developed
involves using a chemical technique to
essentially denature the antibodies from
the tissue and this is a very gentle
technique that we've developed
um it's very rapid and this allows us to
do multi-round immunolabling it's
essentially like an antibody eraser
um and so we can take a tissue you can
see on the far left panel we have a
tissue before staining obviously we see
nothing then we stain it with our
selected antibodies we can strip the
tissue which gives us back the tissue as
it was with no signal and now to
demonstrate that we've fully removed all
of the primary and the secondary
antibodies from that tissue we add just
the secondary antibody here to
demonstrate that indeed all the primary
has been removed and we get no
background signal then we can repeat
with new markers in this case we just
demonstrated that the antigenicity is
preserved we can stain with the same
markers and we get in almost
indistinguishable image one of the
coolest advantages of this technique in
the eyes of many Pathologists is that
after you're done collecting all this
fluorescent data you can still go back
and get an h e slide or cross-validate
with conventional immunohistochemistry
techniques and so it makes it very easy
to cross-validate this new technique
with existing with the existing
Pipelines
so this is all the the critical
instrument that allows us to do this is
in our lab is the Imperial Versa and so
this allows us to do Multiplex Channel
multiple Channel slide scanning at 40x
on these samples extremely rapidly
usually takes between 15 minutes to an
hour for these samples depending on the
size we get extremely high image quality
they're extremely well suited for
quantitative analysis and this allows us
to move directly into our next part of
the pipeline
so the most important part of this
process
um at least from the from a data science
standpoint is assembling these images
together into one continuous image if
you're going to do co-localization of
these different biomarkers in the cell
population analysis that's required for
tissue cytometry then we have to make
sure that the different rounds of
Imaging have perfectly aligning cells
the way that we accomplish this is by
using a technique that's known as
computational elastic co-registration
this is a technique that was originally
developed to help
um essentially Stitch satellite images
together way back several decades ago
but has been re-adapted for use in
bioimaging and so we actually used for
for this particular project an image J
plug-in that's publicly available and
free which essentially takes the dappy
channels of the different rounds of
Imaging uses those as a guide and
manages to align these images by
slightly deforming
um The Space Between the cells to
account for the slight deformations that
happen when you remove the coverslip and
repeat the process of staining this
allows us to get one contiguous image
set out of our uh you know out of our
Multiplex image run and that way we can
get a single image with 10 12 15
channels which represent each of the
markers that we're trying to look at in
this panel
so how does this all fit together
so in the next couple slides we'll show
you an example of how we've applied this
technique to take a a look at the
patient at a couple of patients and
understand the differences between the
immune cell population Within These
patients so what we sought to do was
develop a panel of 12 targets um you can
see the targets listed on this slide
here they're mostly for T cells inside
toxic T cells we have some memory detail
markers in here we're looking at
proliferating markers we have pan CK in
there to distinguish between the tumor
regions and the non-tumor stroma regions
as well as some checkpoint markers such
as PD P1 and pdl1 and so we put together
this panel and labeled three different
patients who were all suffering from the
same the same type of breast cancer and
you can see the representative images
here displayed with a zoomed in cutout
down below and as you can see from a
quick glance there's not a huge amount
of difference between these patients
here
um and so
moving along here
um for each of these patients we get a
13 Flex really image stack where we have
12 antibody targets a channel for each
one as well as the nuclear stain
um here's just a representation of that
um the composite image is shown on the
left
um and in the middle you're seeing a
sequential uh essentially video of the
different channels going one after the
other on the same image and off to the
right you can see just a montage of that
sequence
so this enables us to get really
beautiful multi-channel composite images
that look really cool and you know they
go up on the wall but but now what right
this is this doesn't really tell us a
lot
um here we're looking at you know 12
different channels it at the end of the
day there's only so many colors your
eyes can see
um so these images are pretty but they
don't really tell you that much on their
own
um The Next Step of this process
involves computational analysis and so
we utilize image analysis software to do
cell segmentation and marker
co-localization
um so we utilize
um one of several pieces of software we
have several pieces of software we've
developed internally we also use image J
as well as the commercially available
software Halo to process these image
sets depending on the needs from that
image analysis we get huge data so we
get usually more than a million rows per
sample since there's so many cells that
we're detecting in these in these
patient tumors
we take that huge amount of data and we
feed it through some open source data
analysis pipelines that allow us to
generate the conventional Scatter Plots
that that are typically produced when
doing flow cytometry analysis
just to point out the kind of data that
we get for this analysis is also
compatible with flowjo and other
commercially available flow cytometry
software for those who are more
comfortable with it we just wanted to
emphasize that you don't need commercial
software to do this kind of analysis a
very straightforward and can be
reproduced with a basic understanding of
python coding and some of these open
source libraries
so um what is this overall process of of
doing the data analysis for tissue
cytometry
um so first off with the raw data we
filter by size and shape and co-localize
the signals
um then we do some processing such as
background subtraction normalization log
scaling
um and finally we will apply our actual
analysis this is where we're doing the
gating and Counting the statistical
analyzes and one of the advantages that
we have of doing tissue cytometry is we
can do spatial analysis so after we're
done looking at cell populations direct
co-localizations we can dive into which
cell populations were located near one
another in the tissue and that's
critically important for understanding
the roles of the multiple immune cell
phenotypes play in the progression of or
in the progression of
so here's just a representative example
of some selected flow cytometry or sorry
tissue cytometry Scatter Plots here
um and just for a point of uh for of
emphasizing how much data we're really
dealing with when we've got 12 markers
we have 132 one-to-one primary marker
comparisons and if we want to compare
The Coincidence of every marker to every
other marker well that's 12 factorial
possible phenotypes about 500 million
possible combinations to look at if you
want to be complete and so obviously
that's a lot of data so the best way to
do this is is obviously systematically
um and driven by hypotheses and so we
were particularly interested in
understanding the differences in the T
Cell exhaustion between these patients
and so you can see here on the top we
have the Scatter Plots representing the
pd1 intensity is the y-axis and on the
top of the cd3a intensity is the x-axis
and you can see here patient two
displays a particular a particular shift
in its phenotype
um compared to Patient one and we do
that same Trend with patient three
patient one has a significantly higher
relative percentage of CD3 and pd1
positive cells this would be exhausted T
cells compared to Patient two and
patient three
um patient two of patient three we see a
much smaller percentage of the total T
Cell population expressing the pd1
marker this goes hand in hand with what
we see when we look at the pdl1
expression in the tumor and so the
figure on the bottom we see pdl1
intensity in the y-axis and pansy K
intensity on the x-axis and here we see
we have two distinct populations of of
cells in our samples we have a a number
of pdl1 pan CK positive cells and we
also have a number of cells that Express
pdo1 that are not pan CK expressing
um and so you can see when we look at
the bar graph out on right patient one
had a significant a significant decrease
in the I guess significantly fewer pdl1
pan CK negative cells compared to
Patient two or patient 3.
moving along here we were interested in
understanding that tumor Associated
macrophages and so this is where we
could start to look at the advantages of
a spatial analysis and so in our study
we can we can correlate the cd68
positive cells with the nearby pan CK
positive cells and do a scatter plot
here to look at the relative expression
of cd68 in the region where we see panty
K positive cells so you can see at the
figure on the top we have a kind of
bimodal distribution between our three
our three patients we have inpatient one
a significant significantly higher
concentration of our macrophages
contained within the tumor in comparison
to the stroma where a patient two and
patient three show very similar relative
percentage of macrophages in the uh in
the tumor region compared to the stroma
and so to summarize in patient one we're
seeing a significant decrease in the
tumor-associated macrophages in the
stroma compared to patients two and
three
now finally the spatial analysis is what
really brings this tissue cytometry to
the Forefront of interest to Amino
oncology because of the way that we do
this analysis from the actual
immunohisto from the
immunohistofluorescence images we can
take the data analysis and start to
bucket these cells into the distance
from cell types of interest and so we
were particularly interested here in
understanding the engagement between T
cells and tumor Associated macrophages
in patient one since we saw such a
distinct difference in some of the other
um in the in the T Cell exhaustion and
some of the other factors that we
measured here in patient one and so when
we generated a histogram of the
um of the distribution of the distances
between CD3 cells and the nearest cd68
positive cell
um we see these figures that that are
are shown in the middle here and so
looking at the top one
um we're looking at uh the distance
between your CD3 positive cells and cd68
cells you can see that patient one has a
considerably higher percentage of its T
Cell population in close proximity to
cd68 positive cells and on the graph at
the bottom we're looking at the
histogram of distances between CD3 and
pd1 positive cells and the nearest td68s
uh near cd68 positive cell and you can
see that Trend continues here we have a
much higher percentage of the total
population of exhausted T cells in close
proximity to a cd68 cell within the
tumor in patient one compared to
patients two and patient three
so to summarize
um tissue cytometry is possible by
combining Multiplex Amino histochemistry
digital slide scanning and open source
data processing packages the sequential
multi-round immunohistochemistry
technique that we use allows for 10 to
20 targets to be labeled in a single
sample and this enables rapid
multi-parametric data analysis so that
we can explore the cell populations
within archives ffpe tissues specimens
the differential analysis of cell
populations in archive patient tumor
biopsies is rapid it's quite inexpensive
and you get a huge Matrix of
quantitative data for analysis
we end up with an extremely high
statistical power from this type of
analysis since we end up measuring
millions of cells in every single sample
and it's a it's a relatively High
throughput
um with our Technique we can do 50 to
100 slides per day per scanner that we
have
um we have two verses running pretty
much around the clock here
um but it's a it's a fairly High
throughput technique for for
histopathology
um most importantly in my opinion is the
ability to then do the spatial analysis
and understand the network of immune
cells and how they're interacting and
contributing to changes in the
progression of the of the disease
so there are a few limitations to this
technique so compared to flow cytometry
we have a much lower dynamic range
um the the images typically take 8-bit
images and so we're dealing with you
know between 0 and 255
um as our possible intensity values
um that can make it a little bit
trickier to get separation between your
cell populations unless you're careful
in how you do your data processing
because a lot of tissues have
autofluorescence this requires either
background correction or some kind of
chemical processing ahead of time to
reduce the background
um
course since these tissues are fixed you
cannot isolate the cells easily after
this analysis and because these tissues
have often archived for decades they all
require very careful antigen retrieval
and it's well known that some antigens
are destroyed by ffpe processing so not
every Target will remain available in
archived specimens
so next steps at least on the physical
side we're currently expanding this for
the analysis of tissue microarrays so
that we can offer more complex services
for patient stratification we're next
incorporating a number of panels to
measure aspects about the extracellular
Matrix and tumor microenvironment we're
currently in the process of validating a
wide library of standard panels for
amine markers and other disease markers
and we're continuing to improve our
image analysis techniques by
incorporating AI where it fits best
um so with that I'll draw our
presentation here to a close
um and I'll be happy to take any
questions from the audience and thank
you so much uh for your attention
um
just about do it
thank you Tom for that informative
presentation
just a quick reminder to our audience on
how to submit questions simply type them
into the Q a box and click on the send
button we will answer as many questions
as we have time for
our first question is is this technique
applicable to live cells or fixed cells
that's a great question um so it's not
really applicable to live cells we're
currently validating the stripping
technique and seeing if we can come up
with a with a gentler technique that
wouldn't affect the cell viability so
this is mostly for fixed cells and
tissues it does work well with 3D cell
culture models as well as adherent cells
and so that technique could be applied
in that manner
great thank you
next question can you filter cells by
morphology
oh yeah that's a great question so um
you know since we're doing the image
analysis process we can exclude cells
based on size and shape
um in a similar manner as you can do
with flow cytometry this allows us to
pick out cells that are eliminate cells
that are may be picked up as a mitotic
uh daughter cells or something like that
um so we can add that that layer of
analysis to the uh to the to the
pipeline as well
great next question can confocal images
be used
um yeah actually so we frequently use
this technique on both with our our
versus a slide scanner as well as our
confocal microscope that we have on hand
um it works quite well with confocal in
the same manner um as it does with the
slide scanner
um you can you know use a sample to get
multiple rounds of labeling and do the
same kind of analysis
um even you can get a little bit uh
better results with the confocal since
you get higher resolution
um and a crispr image and so it usually
facilitates the image analysis process
of course the trade-off is it's lower
than the slide scanner
all right thanks next question
um and it looks like this might be the
only the last one we have time for
is this data compatible with
commercially available flow cytometry
plotting software like flojo
um yeah that's a great question so the
the output of this data pipeline is
essentially a CSV table and that can be
easily imported into flojo and other
cytometry software that can import CSV
data so it's in a pretty standardized
format that can be used with with
commercially available tools as well
well great thank you Tom
um do you have any final comments that
you'd like to add
I'm not really this is a it's an
exciting technique that we're uh we're
currently developing towards youth in uh
clinical trial
um clinical trials and evaluation of
drug effect and patient selection
um so it's a promising technique that
we've got a lot of traction with we
expect to continue to expand this over
the next couple years um and and find
more applications for it as we get
closer to the clinic
well a big thank you to Tom and thank
you to our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions we
will address any questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during our on-demand period via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this session webcast will be available
on demand after the event
that's all for this session thank you
for joining us and we hope you've
enjoyed the presentation bye for now